are you posting videos over and over
again on your channel and not getting
any views I know it can be frustrating
because I know you're putting time into
these videos and it feels like no one is
watching well that's exactly how
Cassandra felt she was working hard to
make videos around her full-time job but
nothing was clicking but after being a
part of our monthly group coaching
program here at think media she made one
tweak in her strategy and all of a
sudden she started getting 10,000 views
a day on her channel and making income
on autopilot her story's incredible and
in this episode she's gonna share this
strategy with you and make sure that you
stick around until the end because she
shares what she wished she would have
done sooner to get ahead on YouTube
welcome to the think marketing show the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm your host Heather Torres and I'm
Sean kennel and we're from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we are fired up you're here this show is
dedicated to helping you learn how to
get your content notice and the latest
money-making strategies that are working
right now online so whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel or you're
ready to maximize video across all of
social media then this podcast is for
you hello and welcome back to the think
marketing podcast I'm so excited for
today's episode because I am sitting
here with Cassandra Thompson from gas
Thompson consulting who really helps
people land their careers and build kind
of their portfolio as a professional but
it's crushing it on YouTube on LinkedIn
and we're gonna actually be talking
about four tips for YouTube today plus
we're getting a chance to highlight one
of our inner circle members who has just
been a rockstar student she's been doing
some cool stuff with putting together a
course that's now been selling is like a
tripwire we're gonna get into all of
that but how are you doing I'm good it's
fun to be here it's fun to have you on
the show it's been awesome to have you a
part of our community over the years but
I've just been so impressed with just
the results that you're getting with the
action that you've been taking and
we're gonna get into that but for those
that are just meeting you what's kind of
your backstory as far as what you do
professionally yes so I'm a career
consultant and speaker I help people
build relationships to achieve career
goals so whether that's their next
promotion job searching or even in a
business and my background was in
television so I was in casting for a
long time and made a leap to become on
the career side I love that and when was
it that you first got into creating
content and building your brand online
yeah
well I've had LinkedIn since it started
but with YouTube it was about three
years ago so what is that she says - Wow
can't talk 2017 I love that and now your
YouTube channel is like over 40,000
subscribers yeah one of your videos is
coming up on a million views yes and
another ones you said is growing even
faster
yes it's gonna surpass that what before
we get into the tips is kind of an
overview of the power of YouTube you've
been consistent now for three years
you've really been dialing your strategy
over the last year why should every
buddy viewing and listening double down
on YouTube and pay attention at YouTube
for building their brand number one
because I think it's a great way to help
people if you're on it for educational
or business purposes it's a great way to
be able to help people build a community
and then on the more functional side I
think YouTube is the best platform to
then take from and disseminate
everywhere else so it's great for that
as well I totally agree and you're
getting results and and speak to even
just in our inner circle program we
talked about creating like a baby off
her baby course and you did that cuz
you're a massive action taker but then
you've also kind of repositioned it as
just kind of a low ticket offer and it's
selling kind of like crazy because of
YouTube what are some of the results
you've been getting yeah so I created
the baby offer or like the mini course
it's kind of this sort of thing you can
do in an hour and I wasn't really
promoting it it was in my description
and then I made it my tripwire when you
sign up for my free Miam an interview
prep checklist after you've signed up it
pops up saying like hey do you want this
course for only $9
I sell probably three a day which is not
gonna pay my rent but it takes care of
all my business expenses including like
a VA and that's a lot of passive income
because the videos you've already made
right and your list is building your
you're making some income and it's
really just the tip of the iceberg which
is kind of why we talk about it because
you from there you can scale up yeah
definitely no it's shocking to to may
have all I had to do was takes I mean
the course was already there I had to
make a landing page it took an hour and
it's bringing in such great income every
month so it's great I love that and then
there's also they always say the
difference between like a paying
customer and just like somebody gives
you their email is huge yeah so being
able to go to the next step or to do
consulting with you or coaching with you
like they're already in another level
right yeah that's why I did it is
somebody talked about how you get them
to pay for this a person who's paid is I
think 70% more likely to buy from you
again well then we are we are making
this at a discounted rate that's right
man that's so awesome but let's get into
these tips and you now again you're
getting massive momentum on YouTube how
often do you post so I was posting twice
a week I am reading starting this month
and going down to once a week to really
make it like really fine-tune some
things and how do you sustain that like
how long does that take you to you batch
videos I have batch for it since day one
so I do all my planning at one point all
my scripting is done over a week and
then I batch all videos on a Saturday
morning amazing yeah that's super cool
and your first tip is consistency what
do you mean by that so if you are just
starting out you have to show up every
every week or whatever your plan was now
you just heard me say I'm switching my
plan but I'm still showing up every week
and I think in the beginning or even six
months in you might have six views like
that's something people don't talk about
all the time is it might take a while to
build and I think the mistake I made was
I got frustrated and when I was watching
it took like a five month break and came
back and went you are showing up every
week whether you have zero views on last
week's video or not just keep coming
back because
consistency builds viewership more than
anything else I love that and yeah
consistency is absolutely key and and
YouTube takes time to build momentum yes
you're experiencing that momentum now so
I hope that can be just encouraging if
you're watching or listening to this
that it's gonna start out and be
discouraging even you're gonna be
putting more work than the results
you're getting but eventually you kind
of hit a tipping point where now you're
experiencing the benefits of videos
breaking out they're bringing you
subscribers growth whether you're
working or not right yes and I think
that's true I the video that is my top
video right now it had been filmed or it
had been on YouTube for four months
before all the sudden wait it has a
thousand views but where did that come
from and then it something took off in
the algorithm that it just started
gaining like crazy but if you looked at
the analytics it is a flat line and then
goes up yeah four months after it was
posted and I love that you say that
because from all of our research and
studying our multiple channels we are
seeing videos pop at day 30 day 45 day
55 which and there's not a lot you can
do around that the point is put out
quality content be consistent and then
trust the process because as you keep
putting out videos you don't necessarily
know which video is gonna pop right but
you just want to stay consistent which
brings us to number two which is double
down on what's working so once you see
some videos working what have you done
right so I did content on interviewing
like one question at a time I think I
did four job in job yes I always say
interviewing coz to me that's the only
kind but this is an interview so yes job
interviews in particular and I had done
like four of them and then that one took
off and I went well now we are doing the
top 10 questions so let me do an
individual video for each one of the
questions then I did a top 5 interview
job interview questions then a top 10
interview questions and then what other
job interview pieces do people have oh
they get nervous around job interviews
let's do a video just on that so that is
like the cornerstone of my content now
branching out into other things but that
is what people really connected with me
on and so I it just seemed natural that
you're gonna focus in even harder on
that thing
well that's powerful because yes it's
the cornerstone but it's the cornerstone
of growth great growth leads to
subscribers leads to building
relationships with you which gives the
opportunity to talk about other things
yes which you found that thing the topic
the video idea that triggered growth for
you so you kept doubling down so I'd
love to hear that if you're watching
this on youtube tell us in the comments
have you found that hot topic in your
channel or a particular video that's
blown up you know for me it was best
camera for YouTube seems obvious now but
years ago I didn't realize that it was
really I really want to know what camera
I need help with just the camera he
wasn't even microphone or other things
those do okay
it was camera and so every year I make
the same one then I start doing best
vlogging camera best 4k camera yeah and
all that like spin-offs right and so
that's exactly what you did that's so
powerful yeah I also bought my DSLR
because of you so yeah I love that and
tip number three here is trim the fluff
what do you mean by that
yeah so I think when you're getting
started on YouTube you hear all the
different things about like it needs to
be this month like there was a time
period it's gone now but there was a
time period where everyone said longer
content is doing it 12 15 minute content
then it was shorter whatever what I
realized is it doesn't matter what any
of that says it's how long do you need
to tell the story or to give the
information and then get out people are
busy they came if if you're a Content if
your content is like mine in that
educational space people came for an
answer to solve a problem solve the
problem and go and so I will give a
formula or how to answer something give
an example because I think people do
want an example but they don't need for
examples so I give the example and then
it's hey bye get the freemium you know
watch the next video
yep let's move you on to that where I
answer your other question instead of
trying to keep you on this platform
because also people work I think a lot
of people are focused on average view
duration and wanting that to be high and
not thinking about average percentage
viewed and if you're getting in and
getting out your percentage viewed is
through the roof and I think that's why
some of my videos are where they are now
yeah that's very powerful and we've
noticed that if you can get your the
average amount of people watching your
videos to watch at least sixty percent
or more it triggers the algorithm like
crazy so if you optimize your content a
great friend of the thick marketing
podcast and mentor in my life chalene
johnson always says and you know the
quote be brief be bright be fun and be
done
don't try to stretch out the content
keep it concise keep it high-impact if
you can get a few people no matter how
many subscribers you have you got a
hundred subscribers watching sixty
percent or more it's gonna start
spreading in the algorithm because
YouTube values time on platform and so
really optimize those videos yep I love
that and so we're gonna get into tip
number four in just a second but
wherever you're watching or listening to
us it would mean the world to us if
you're getting value to hit the like
button and rate or review the podcast
and also share this with somebody that
needs to hear this I love your story
it's so inspiring to see the growth to
see the results you're getting and the
journey because I know that sometimes
when you're trying to build a business
grow a YouTube channel or social media
platforms it can be tough so we'd love
it if your again value about this think
about that one person that would love to
think marketing podcast and share this
with them but tip number four is invest
in your education what do you mean by
that so I think I spent a long time just
watching everybody's free content which
there is an amazing free content out
there this is amazing free content right
I think I held on too long to that and
trying to just do it on my own and just
like anything in life you should seek
help so if that is all you can afford is
fifteen dollars by YouTube secrets go by
the book it's it's going to help you if
you can invest more join somebody's
course join a group coaching program
whatever level you can be at but I wish
I had invested in it more quickly
because I think I would have grown
further faster yeah
absolutely and you know I would love to
ask you as a shameless plug to inner
circle how long have you been a part of
inner circle now I want to say it was
May of 2019 that's amazing and so you've
been in there for months and we talk
about a lot of different social media
strategies LinkedIn YouTube what's kind
of been your experience and why that
program has been valuable so I will say
group coaching is super valuable to me
and the way you all are doing it you're
learning one less in a month I think
with a lot of things we all want all the
information right now like no no just
give it all to me
we can't process that all in that time
we can't implement it and so it's been
really helpful to know like okay I have
this session once a month I will block
out the time I will learn whatever that
topic is and then I will spend the month
implementing it and having the group to
kind of bounce questions off of hear
from each other has been really helpful
too
but it it creates to me the monthly part
creates accountability and it creates
enough time to take action
not to mention like you have the whole
vault of everything that came before so
if for some reason one month I went oh
yeah I've got this thing I can go look
up something else that came before me
and learn that thing yeah no doubt well
really appreciate you and just love that
you're an action taker hashtag action
taker an inner circle and if you want to
learn more about that you can go to
think inner circle dot-com cast if
people want to connect with you where
can they find you online and what are
you up to yeah so two best places to
follow me our YouTube it's cast Thompson
career advice and then I'm on LinkedIn
it's my full name cassandra thompson and
i'm on instagram if you wanted to see
the behind the scenes in my life y'all
I'm not a great Instagram or I'll be
honest but I'm at Casa Thompson
consulting so that's it I love that well
thank you so much for coming on to think
marketing podcast it is so uplifting
Shawn to hear about success stories like
Cassandra who are making a difference
online helping people but are also able
to make this passive income yeah I agree
and the other thing that I love about
her story though is that great things
take time
you know and I think it's important to
remember that YouTube is a marathon and
not a sprint
growing a business is a marathon and not
a sprint and just hearing about her
persistence her tenacity but also the
fact that we can accelerate our success
because like wisdom is the shortcut you
know I think like there's two ways to
get wisdom one is your own mistakes you
know and that's the slowest way and the
most painful because you just have to
experience it yourself and the fastest
way though is to learn from other
people's mistakes you know that's why we
started this podcast is because we've
done a lot of things right but a lot of
things wrong and we really believe that
being connected this podcast as well as
some of our other programs can shorten
your learning curve by really
seventy-five percent I mean I've been
thinking about our journeys together as
entrepreneurs and separately in
different businesses and endeavors you
know we've been at this for over a
decade and we've had a lot of failures
we've had a lot of setbacks and I know
that we are fully confident that we
could shave 75% that like it's still
gonna take two and a half three you know
three years to launch and build
something significant but it doesn't
have to take ten unless you go at it
alone and so we want to thank you that
you don't have to do this alone and for
thank you for being a part of this
podcast we have so many future episodes
to share with you and man the takeaways
of that episode were killer shows the
power of YouTube still today because
she's relatively new on the platform and
she's growing right now in the 20 20
climate in 2021 it's not too late to
start it's not too late to punch fear in
the face and press record and Kass is a
great example of all that yeah and I'm
really excited to learn from Kass and
from all of the speakers that we're
gonna be having at grow with video live
this year
yeah I agree we've got some incredible
things planned for our event this year
if you haven't got your tickets yet grow
with video live.com and you can see all
of our speakers you can see everything
that you can expect yeah and you know
this is a time in the episode Sean where
we want you to take your next step with
us it's so important that we're giving
you valuable content that you can take
action
right now and so I want you to pull over
if you're driving or grab your notebook
if you're sitting at home and I want you
to take action I want you to literally
set aside time right now to write down
what was that aha moment you know what
was it that was in Cass's story that you
connected with and that you're like I
can do this I'm ready to do X Y or Z I
want you to write those things down in
your notebook and then I love for you to
take out your calendar next you know me
calendar blocking so I want you to take
out that calendar and I want you to
write in when are you gonna do that
what's the deadline for that next
project because what gets scheduled gets
done and it's so important that you are
the one that is actually moving the ball
down the court it's up to you as an
entrepreneur who's building just like
Cassandra is you are the one that needs
to be taking the actions to move
yourself forward yeah we also want to
thank you for all the incredible support
and feedback we've gotten about the
think marketing podcast it's been part
of our vision for a couple years but
we're still in the early stages of this
podcast and we want to thank you for
watching for liking for reviewing and
supporting it and we've been lately
doing some shoutouts for the comment of
the week and so for everybody that's
left a comment thank you so much but
this week's comment is from Vanessa and
it says this I've been waiting for Sean
Connell and his team to share all their
marketing experience in growing multiple
seven-figure and six-figure income
streams I followed just a little bit of
their online video tips and even when I
take long breaks from YouTube I still
gain subscribers because of using their
methods I'm super excited about this
podcast and I cannot wait for the next
episode Vanessa thank you so much for
reviewing the podcast and if you haven't
heard we're actually giving away two
tickets to grow a video live just for
reviewing the podcast there's a few
simple steps to do to be entered to win
so if you go to think marketing show.com
that's think marketing show calm you'll
just see a few simple steps to do and if
you review and rate this podcast not
only may you be shot it out on the
comment of the week but you could also
be entered to win two tickets to the
number one video marketing event for
entrepreneurs
happening in Las Vegas this year yes and
we just want to say thank you thanks for
being connected here with us thank you
for coming along this journey with us as
we started this podcast and as we hope
to be with you every single week to help
you go further and faster and a way to
stay connected with us is to actually
subscribe hitting the red button on
YouTube to subscribe will allow you to
see when our newest episodes come out
and if you are listening you can go to
iTunes and you could subscribe there but
that's the best way to stay connected
with us and we hope that each one of
these episodes is bringing you value
that's gonna help your business grow
this year and beyond thanks for sticking
with us and we'll see you in the next
episode